on today's show we take a deep dive into
standardized testing and how to help
your kids when they're struggling with
taking the big tests
and in a dr john deloney's show first we
take a couple's call
and it's a doozy stay tuned
what is happening this is john with the
dr john dolone's show
so glad you're with us hope you're doing
well
i hope you're laughing some if you're
not laughing put yourself in a position
to laugh or if you're grieving if things
suck make sure you got people around you
they'll just sit there with you and not
give you stupid advice we'll just sit
there with you
so glad you're with us today we got a
special episode today
and so i'm glad you're here if you want
to be on this show i would love to have
you
give us a call at 1-844-693-3291
it's 1-844-693-3291
education mental health relationships
parents
boundaries all of it whatever is going
on in your life co-workers that you're
struggling with boston just
whatever is going on give me a shout
political i don't know how much help
i'll be on political issues
somebody told me on the internet the
other day i should keep my mouth shut
about political issues
um so yeah let's do some more of those
that'd be fun um whatever's going on or
go to johndaloni.com
show and you can fill out the online
form there goes to kelly
if you call the number 1-844-693-3291
you're going to leave a message
let kelly know what's going on she'll
check out the message give you a call
back
and we'll have you on the show all right
so here's an email i get with some
regularity
and so i want to take just a brief
second to begin the show to
answer the email the email i get is this
delony you talk a lot about beliefs
versus
values on your show can you give some
examples of
each yes
let's take something let's take me and
my wife okay
let's say that one of our values is
to always make sure our kids know
they're loved
right one of our values is to connect
with our children
this isn't it our house but i'm just
using us because it's easy
so my belief about connecting with let's
say my
son could be
i need to give him a list of things he
needs to do
he needs to have some accomplishments he
needs to mow my yard
he needs to take out the trash he needs
to do
these things and then he'll know
that men are valued by what they
accomplish
and achieve and what they do right i had
one guy let me know once it's not
human being it's human doing right
i had another friend of mine a close
personal friend that was
that said men are utilitarian right so
i'm going to connect with him
by teaching him to do things and my wife
may want to connect with him by asking
him how his day went
asking him how'd you feel about today
what was some good stuff what was some
bad stuff
by hugging him by looking him in the eye
and letting him know that
he's got value right we both share a
value which is
letting our kids know we love them we
both share value which is we're going to
connect with our kids
our belief about how to do that is
different
and that's why couples read parenting
books that's why they go to
marriage counseling that's why they talk
to other people who have
more kids than they do or have older
kids than they
have been through it so that that value
that they share
which is we want to love and connect
with our kid can be shaped by new
beliefs
one of the most important values on
earth
is changing your beliefs nothing not
always changing your values
but seeking to change beliefs that's why
you have mentors that's why you read
books that's why you watch shows right
that's why you
listen to podcasts because you have a
belief about the way things work and
somebody teaches you something new
you either look at the data you hear
their experiences you learn from them
and you go oh my gosh i believe
something totally different
a value i have is
that i live in a great country my belief
about how
it is a wonderful place to live is x
and then somebody else tells you well
here's our experience and you go whoa
i believe something different now i
think the four most important words
in the english language are i changed my
mind
i changed my mind i love it when a
scientist says i changed my mind i love
it
there's no such thing as a politician
that's ever said i changed my mind i
would love that if it ever happened
i love it when my wife says i changed
her like she changed her mind i love
what my friends say they change their
mind
i love it it's a personal thing that i
love
when i find out oh my gosh i changed my
mind i have a different belief about
this now
what i want to hang on tight what i want
to hang on tight too is my values it
takes a lot to shift my values because
my values are usually pretty simple
mutual respect and dignity right
um
honor my wife honor my children right
be accountable do excellent work right
be a person of faith i i want to hang on
to those things
i want my beliefs to shift right one
more thing you know i work here with
dave ramsey
i might we share the same value we love
people and behind closed doors i haven't
met few people who love
human beings more than dave ramsey a
belief that we share
is different that i might say i value
that person so much
and the best way i can show my value
them is to be really quiet
and to listen and dave might think the
best way i can show that person i value
them
is to rattle their cage and say what are
you doing
right just a different belief about how
to meet a value
and so i think most of us if we really
dug in our values are very very similar
i really believe that most of us if we
distill down our values are similar
it's our beliefs that are different if
we can hold our beliefs
lightly and our values tightly oh my
gosh
most of us value healthy families
most of us value laughing really hard
and living lives of joy
most of us value being able to help our
neighbors
the question is what are our beliefs
about how help works
what are our beliefs about how to get
joy what are in laughter right
what are our beliefs about what a
healthy family is and what it looks like
those are things that can shift and mold
and shape and move
and here's what i've found most people
are reluctant
to change their beliefs because bad
beliefs sometimes hurt people
sometimes i've been yelling and
screaming about a thing for five years
and i look back in my wake when i get a
new belief and realize
oh no i've hurt people it's
easier to double down on my belief than
to actually stop and turn around and say
oh my gosh i'm so sorry
i need to go make that right
i gotta say i'm sorry so we just keep on
going with our belief our belief our
belief
no man be willing to say i'm sorry be
willing to look in the rearview mirror
and turn around and go back and pick
people up that you ran over
be willing to say i didn't know and now
that i know i'm going to do better
right so great question that's the
difference between values and beliefs
um feel free to shoot me a message on
one of the internet's platforms and if
you got more questions and we will go
from there
all right let's get to the phones let's
go to angela in midland texas what's up
angela
hey how are you dr john i'm good how are
you i'm good thank you all for taking my
call
for sure thanks for calling in so what's
up i have a question about my kiddo
this is star testing and
you just gave me the
uh for those of you who don't know the
star testing
is the texas standardized test
it's that one obnoxious measure that
they
you just gave me the whole like the
blast
way to go angela all right so your kid
is prepping or taking the
star test standardized test and
i'm sure he's loving it so you're trying
you're calling me to ask how can you
take your kid's love for standardized
tests down a notch is that right
right he gets anxiety about it he's a
good kid he's a good smart kid
and at the school you know the teachers
stress about it and they've relayed that
to the kiddos and at home
we try to calm him down about it but he
still gets stressed about it and how can
we help him with that
yeah i have so many feelings
on this call oh man
all right can i hijack your call for a
second angela
and just okay and then i promise i
promise i'll answer it back in full is
that cool
yeah it's perfect okay here's the thing
um congratulations world we have
sucked all love and joy out of
learning and we've made it about an end
result
right so here in tennessee my kid just
finished the standardized testing cycle
they got a few weeks left to school
you know what they're doing nothing
nothing
they're having parties and watching
movies you know why
because the only reason you shove info
in your brain
is to barf it up on a test that's what
our kids are learning
that the only reason you get info in
your mind
is so that you can regurgitate it for
some
power in your life so you can be ranked
on a thing
and then once we're done with that you
can do whatever you want
just let's eat cupcakes and run around
like a maniacs and watch movies and
whatever
right so here's the thing i actually
don't mind assessments i think they're
valuable i think they're good
i they come with a couple of caveats
number one
they've got to be fair right some kids
don't know math
some kids are starving when they get to
school in the morning
or they slept two hours last night
because they have a chaotic home
has nothing to do with math has to do
with sitting down and trying to learn
something when their system underneath
them is is an earthquake
right so assessment's got to actually
measure what's trying to measure
um it's got to assess what it's actually
trying
it's got to be fair and it's got to
assess what it's trying to assess it's
got to measure what it's trying to
measure right
so an example that is uh if you take a
10 year old
and plop them down in front of a
computer screen for three and a half
hours
and say here's your standardized math
test
you're testing whether a kid can sit
still for three and a half hours you're
not testing whether they know math
right can they sit for a long time and
be focused
not can they actually get the math
concepts right
where does some of the drama from this
come from it comes from i sat with
scholars on this issue i've talked to
some brilliant people i've
lived this issue my wife's a scholar and
some of these issues
when you tie funding to assessment
outcomes
everyone's going to follow the money
that's life that's what we do that's why
we do it
now there's an economic incentive to
drill and kill
we're going to cut out arts we're going
to cut out pe all that stuff becomes a
waste of time
music classes things that we know
pedagogically
enhance and change a kid's brain lets
them breathe lets their brain grow new
synapses all that stuff
we cut all that out because you have to
know these math facts
go go more worksheets more worksheets
more skills more skills more worksheets
and so on
because we've got to follow the money
right
so here's the thing i don't mind
assessments i think they're good i think
they are great
markers of success along a journey right
they're important but they're not the
central orbit your child is a central
orbit
okay all right so thank you for letting
me hijack your call that's me being
dramatic here
yeah um okay so when you say your kid
does
stresses what does that look like paint
me a picture of a stressed out anxious
child well he keeps uh questioning about
it and what if i don't do good and what
if they hold me back
and i'm telling them that's not even an
issue
um he knows his stuff he's a straight a
student he's 10 years old
but like he's gotten into tears because
he
just stresses about it and i don't i
can't i don't know how to pull from him
what are you stressed about besides what
you've already told me you know
it's you just get stressed about it so
kids kids absorb the tension
of the adults in their life and then
they make that tension their fault
that's all they know
right kids are masters at control you
can control
the room feels out of out of chaos i'm
going to smash something i'm going to
scream and kick and yell i'm gonna throw
a temper tantrum i'm gonna run up and
hug you
i'm gonna make straight a's i'm gonna do
drugs i will get your attention
because i'm gonna control what i can
control and i will figure out a way to
get you right so
when a kid feels that tension when for a
year their teachers have said
if you don't you're getting held back
you're not going to get into that class
that girl won't kiss you you won't go to
college you're going to be a loser right
all that starts when they're 10
that kid your child absorbs that tension
right and makes the outcome their fault
if i don't my teacher fails i feel
everything falls apart right
so i want every parent listening to this
and you too angela
struggle and connection they're good for
kids i want my kid to struggle but i
want i want him to be nervous
i want to recognize that things are
important and there's certain days you
got to show up and perform that's good
for a kid
but i want them to also know that
they can only be successful in those
things when they're in connection
right that's why the army trains
together as a team you can only go do
great things in battle when you are
know that somebody's got your back right
so
um the first thing is i want i'm gonna
give you like three or four things here
okay
the first thing is i don't want every
parents to fall in a trap around a kid
saying things like this is a waste of
time this is no big deal
this is you know um these things are
stupid
even if you believe them because here's
why you start to pit
your kids against your teachers all
right i mean i'm sorry pit you against
your teacher get your
kids teachers i'm not being very clear
i'm all fired up about this
if you are going around saying these
things are stupid stupid dumb waste of
your time they don't mean anything
and your kid's teacher is saying this is
everything
yeah you're asking a child to make a
sophie's choice here
who's telling me the truth my mom or my
my teachers
and if my teachers are lying about this
then what else are they lying about are
they lying about the information or if
my parents are the ones that don't fully
get it
what else are they so i don't want to do
that right i want to let them know that
assessments are important and some days
you got to show up and you got to work
really hard
and i love you no matter what happens
right if you
fall apart i love you no matter what
okay so here's a couple of
of goals here number one i want you to
connect with your kid
what does that mean i want them to see
mom and dad struggle on something
right i want them to see them below a
recipe totally screw it up
did you screw up a work report did you
forget something at the store and have
to go back
i want you to take your kid when you
mess those things up let
them know there's a thing i needed to do
and i blew it i'm totally messed up
right
and then i want you to connect outside
of the classroom success with inside of
the classroom success right so that's
number two is
i want you to when he does something
awesome in soccer and
you probably already do this stuff or
when he works really hard to figure out
how to take the trash can out and he's
too short take trash can out and he
figures out how to get it out
that's when you say hey look you do hard
things and i want you to build a culture
of catching him doing hard things and
calling them out
man you figured out how to get the
lawnmower started you do hard stuff
you figure out hard things because then
that language comes in handy
a year later when they sit down to take
tests and you can say
hey you do hard things and use the same
language
and all of a sudden that pattern runs
through your child's mind and they stand
up a little bit taller
because they've got evidence not of when
they failed
but wow so when you tell a kid hey you
make straight a's you don't have to
worry about this
no they're being told every day you
better worry you better better worry
and so for the year every time they get
straight a's not we knew you could do it
or you're really smart but
you worked hard for this huh or you
didn't have to work hard for this one
and you still managed to get an a is
that right i want to teach them about
hard work i want to teach them about
effort because if man if we focus on the
process the outcomes will take care of
themselves
right and so then i want to teach them
strategies right what is it look like
when his little sister is driving him
bananas and you pull him aside and say
hey
take a breath a deep breath again we are
building
pictures of things that we can use later
on when they're going to have test
anxiety
or when he becomes a teenager and has
relationship anxiety
or when he gets his heart broken by some
evil girl and
he has a reservoir now hey you can do
hard things this really stinks but you
got to get up this morning
you got to go to school he's got a
lifetime of mom
pointing out to him man you can do hard
things
right so i want to build this this whole
um an ecosystem where he knows
struggle's good
mom fails dad falls down sometimes too
and they get themselves back up and it's
not the end of the world
i can do hard things and my mom and dad
point it out and call it out all the
time
and then when it gets to this end thing
mom and mom and teachers in
concert with one another right and then
here's the most important one
no matter what i'm loved
no matter what and if we wait until
hard things show up like honey we will
love you whatever if they don't get that
message in their places
so if honey we will love you no matter
what why'd you
you gotta swing like this you know if we
if they get different messages on a ball
field
or they get different messages at the
dinner table
if they hear us talk about dad
like your dad's a [ __ ] what an idiot
and i'm not saying you do this angela
right up
um or if they hear if dads are talking
bad about mom
kids understand there's a point when
mom and dad don't love each other
anymore there's a point when mom and dad
don't like each other and it usually
comes on the back of a bad performance
or there's moments when dad doesn't
think i did a great job playing
basketball
little league or whatever the thing is
so i want to build an ecosystem where my
kid knows no matter what
so i'm telling you angela this is really
really hard for me
because my kids got a lot of tools to be
a great little league player and he
doesn't really care
he just likes running around his buddies
and we will work on something in the
front yard we'll have fun and man he
will be
smashing the baseball and then he'll get
up in a game
it looks like i i don't know what he
just stands in a whole new way
he's just making it up as he goes and
he'll strike out and he'll just jog back
to the
back to the dog out like hey everybody
and man when he gets done my first thing
is like dude why didn't you stand the
way we practiced for hours and hours
and i've had to train myself i've had to
like
carry through the shame of this thing
and say my first question is
dude did you have so much fun out there
today yes
awesome that's so good when you came up
to bat were you having fun were you
having fun
you're having a blast and i'm aiming for
what is really important here right i
want him to know there's not going to be
a thing he does i don't love him anymore
now if we set up and work on something
really hard and then he doesn't
um achieve i'm going to grieve that with
him if he comes home and says man i'm so
sick of striking out
i'm gonna see what that really stinks
when you strike out i've struck out a
bunch too i hate that for you
just like i talk to you about at work
when i screw this up i tell them every
time james is mean to me i tell him
man hon son i i wore what i thought were
good clothes to work today and
i i didn't james let me know that i was
a failure um
kelly let me know hey i know you thought
you had a good answer on that one called
you didn't
you totally you tanked it um i
i need him to know that so that when he
does come to me with honesty
and let's say man i really failed i
could say yeah i've been there man
remember remember remember and so all
those things together
um one final bonus thing don't be afraid
to look into accommodations to 504
accommodations
some kid needs to take a test by
themselves in a room because they
actually trying to assess math not
what's my performance and
what's the volume of this room and i
hear all the the scratching and clawing
because i'm
hypersensitive in this stage of my
development get your kid the
accommodations they need the 504 stuff
they need if they need extra time if
they need
private room because we're going after
not at a race
does my kid know math it's my kid no
reading
right so get them the accommodations
they need and then teach them
sometimes you got to stand up and say
hey i need some extra help
and that one that ability for them to do
that is so powerful
so powerful moving on as an old guy who
still struggles with asking for help
man and no kid wants to ask for help
it's hard
right so there you go there's some ideas
angela thank you so much for that
bravery for that call
can we please fix the education system
stop tying money to
test outcomes please please please and i
know it's messy and hard and there is no
simple answers
anyone's like i think they should just
you're wrong it's more complex than that
it is i've sat with the scholars i've
sat with politicians it's hard it's a
mess it's hard
but can we please start teaching kids
that learning is fun
it's good and it's enriching it's
beautiful and it's wonderful to change
your mind and learn new things
it's not all about regurgitating
vomiting of a test
that's all angela you're a stud thank
you so much for your call
[Music]
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud
and it seems that everyone has anxiety
i've been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not
and how you can get back on the road of
being whole and well
listen you are not broken and i'm living
proof that you can get your life
back i wrote this book so everyone could
read it not just science nerds like me
and my friends
and i priced it at 10 bucks so that
everyone can afford it this little book
landed on the best seller list and is
now being purchased by the case
and given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country
i don't care if you're a teenager or an
executive or a 75 year old grandmother
this book is for everyone so go to
johndalone.com and get your copy of
redefining anxiety today
all right and next call we're gonna do
something a little bit different
we've got lindsay and xander we're going
to take a couple's call so first on the
dr john dolone show
lindsay and xander are you guys there
yes sir
how are you i'm hey i'm great my
marriage isn't on the line here so this
is
awesome thank you all for being brave
and for giving us a shot here
and to all the listeners we're trying
something new and i want to just
shout out lindsay and xander for their
willingness to call here
so hey how's it going y'all doing all
right
doing pretty good awesome how about you
man
i'm better than i deserve oh well played
i like that all right so
let's do this um lindsay give me a three
minute or so explanation of what's going
on and then xander
i'm gonna ask you to give me your
explanation of what's going on and y'all
are in different cities right
yeah different states oh different
states even better so here's what's
important
you both have to be completely
vulnerable and honest
and this is going to be easier because
you're not looking at each other
watching body positions with each other
oh great
okay so we're zooming now so just
y'all kind of side eye so you don't see
each other all right so lindsay
you walk me through what's going on in
your mind
okay um feels like a bit of a long story
but it's really not um so
xander and i have been dating for about
a year
and i had to
we started out being in the same place
and i had to move away
for graduate school i'm just finishing
up my first year
of my master's
we've had some bumpy patches but we've
made it work this far
and what does bumpy patches mean well
the long distance didn't work out for a
little while
there's a lot of outside influence
that kind of degraded the relationship
for a bit
but we kind of so we we
were not together for a couple months
late last year
and we kind of came back to it and said
no you know
we really want to give this man a shot
and we want to
try again because we don't feel like we
were the only ones
influencing the relationship and so
we've
given it another shot and it's been
really good so far okay so to recap
y'all were together you went to grad
school you ended up
you tried to make it work long term
there was some
anytime somebody says bumpy patches
that's usually really cryptic
for like they stole from me or they
cheated on me with my old roommate
or something like that so then y'all
whatever happened y'all broke up
and you have these quote unquote outside
influences
is that your friends is that his friends
that your parents who
is that your like y'all buy a dog
together like knuckleheads and then the
dog likes one of you more than the other
what's that what's the outside
influences
my parents specifically my mom
and a few of my friends that
i have just been very negative
about the whole thing negative about him
because he's a bum or negative because
it's just so long distance and why are
you tying yourself down so young
and you're in grad school now and and
all that
um
negative because they
seem to think that xander is
controlling and manipulative and
not a good person and we come from very
different backgrounds
and my family is
not supportive of that at all
and just that they
see that they think we don't have very
much in common
and that he's a bad influence and all of
these things
that i don't believe are true at all
okay but they're
very loud about it so that's always my
first question when someone says
my friends think he's controlling a
manipulative my first question is always
well
is he so you're saying no he's a great
influence on you he's not controlling
your manipulative
and he seeks
to he seeks the best for you
yes okay awesome and by the way i didn't
ask that you all married
engaged where where are you or
relationally
uh we're
talking about getting engaged okay so
what what's how long have you been
dating including the breakup
um it was a year
in march okay all right all right so
you have you said i love you yet
oh yeah oh yeah
that's the most affirmative thing you've
said so far um
all right so oh yeah so you love this
guy
your parents think he's manipulative and
controlling he's the worst your friends
think he's
just dragging you along for a ride but i
love him
and then you're going to grad school you
all broke up and
has there been any infidelity here
no okay um only one person answered that
xander
has there been any infidelity here no
they haven't
promise no promise pinky swear to both
of y'all
i'm thinking all right something bad
will happen to you if you're lying
okay so probably not but whatever yeah i
know she'll kick my ass
that too all right so um
all right so zander you tell me paint me
a picture here what's going on
so uh throughout pretty much the entire
year or 15 months that we've been dating
it's felt like almost all of our big
fights that we have
have come from this outside influence
you keep you keep talking about i'm
talking about outside influence based on
what she was talking about
mostly her mother and one of her close
friends okay yeah
let's don't call like y'all are
referring to her mother
like um like she's like a political
state
you know what i mean like the government
no she's mom so let's just start calling
her
mom okay i want to humanize this
quote-unquote outside influence all
right so
her mom and a friend or two um are
really been
pressing on your girlfriend lindsay all
right so go ahead
yeah so it's felt like uh her mom and
one of her best friends have been
trying to speak into her life and uh
change her opinion on me
okay none of the reasons that either of
us have heard from either of them have
been it have seemed like a good enough
reason to
hate me and i
typically wouldn't care too much about
other people's opinions of me in that
way
except for the fact that it uh is making
it hard for
lindsay and i to just be ourselves and
have our own life
so you will never just be yourselves and
have your own life
there's always going to be other people
involved in this thing right
so that is a as a goal isn't a real
objective but also people pleasing
is not healthy either right so why
why does her mom think you're
manipulative and controlling
so like if me and you were just hanging
out fishing
having a beer why and i was like dude
why does her mom hate you so much
what would your answer to that be
it seems to me like uh lindsay's mom
has a view on how lindsay's life should
look
and if it doesn't look exactly like that
this is based on
what what i've talked to her mom about
who i've talked to lindsay about
and it's just what i've seen from their
interactions as well
it feels like if lindsay's life isn't
exactly as a mom
looks she freaks out
so her mom has a picture of what she
want her her her pretty little
daughter's life to look like
and it's not you correct
whether it's because i didn't grow up in
agriculture or
because i'm not done with school yet or
any of the other reasons that she's
given
gotcha okay so i've got a close friend
whose wife grew up
more ag related
and he grew up in the city and that's
caused some significant tension among
family because there's a culture around
ag this is like you'll hear things like
this is who we are
right and then folks from a city or
suburbs
might not speak in that in those terms
sometimes they do i've never heard
someone be like you know what we're a
suburb family like i've never really
heard that
but i have heard we're a like
this is us this is who we are we're
farming people we are outside people we
are
filling the blank people right um
so why have you stuck it out
because the amount the picture that
lindsey and i have seen and talked about
is the clearest picture that i've ever
seen in my life
whenever i talk to god about it he's
told me to stay
and i've we've
broken up a couple of times
she's broken up with me i've broken up
with her and typically when i've
ended it or wanted to it just it felt
like i'm
beating a drum that's not being heard
and the reason i've come back and the
reason she's come back
i think is because we've seen that
change in each other and ourselves
and uh and there's also another
uh wrench that came into play recently
throw it um i went up to visit her
for her birthday in april
at the beginning of april i flew up
there and
we found out a couple of weeks ago that
we're having a kid
and there's another little wrench yep
a little rough yeah guys lead with that
what are you doing
wow how'd you leave that one out all
right
this this is like the big reveal
show i feel like we're on a game show
now and then at the end you're gonna be
like and by the way
um all right so
wow yeah that's a good one so does that
accelerate your plans for
getting married yes okay and
that's been a talking play between us
that we don't necessarily
see eye to eye on okay uh
in my opinion it does accelerate those
plans
we made a um we made a mistake in
having that happen before we were
necessarily ready for it
even though we'll never be fully ready
for it but right
and in my opinion
knowing how we feel about each other and
knowing what we want in life
as well as being able to start our own
family
all that points to for me is
let's start this thing uh and um i know
lindsay's a little
uh a little more hesitant on it than i
am but
how old are you xander you're 23.
okay so this is just two dudes hanging
out for a second
on a little side conversation never
refer
to parenting or your wife's future as
let's do this thing
don't refer to anything about her as
quote unquote this thing
just that's just hashtag um just saying
okay so now we're back to a regularly
scheduled program
all right so let me recap
and then we can kind of get to the core
here
um lindsay you love this dude
xander you love this girl you have been
together 15 months you've had some
breakups here and there
um i'll call them like knucklehead of
breakups y'all are both young
and mom does not think that xander's
the guy for you you've got a friend
who probably has matching outfits i
don't know why that matters
all my friends have matching outfits i
just felt wanted i want to say something
mean about your friend without saying it
to me
um she doesn't like him either and
it's gonna say she has sparkly things on
her boots or whatever so
she doesn't like him and
you're in grad school he's finishing his
undergrad degree and
surprise now you're having a baby
so i guess the drum roll please how can
i help
i guess what it boils down to what we
both
want is how do we make sure
that we are making the right choices
for our little family that we've now
started
how do we know that what we're deciding
to do
is the right thing for us
without everybody else trying to
speak into it and tell us what we need
to be doing with our kid
oh man okay that's a million dollar
question that's a great question
so i'm gonna give you the good news and
the bad news at the same time
okay how do you know what you're doing
is right you don't
but you will always know if you do it
together that you'll be there with each
other
so answering the question of are y'all
going to be in relationship with one
another here that
you are in a relationship with each
other for the rest of your lives
starting now okay
whether you choose to get married
whether you choose to stay boyfriend
girlfriend whether you choose to live in
different states i've got some opinions
on all that
but y'all are officially in a
relationship forever
okay and so the quicker you can wrap
your head around
that that other people don't get a say
into that
it's an is you're having a kid okay you
made a human
congratulations made a made a human
so you're in it together now what other
people's
influence can be whether they're going
to support you in that
whether they are going to walk away from
you guys whether they're going to
abandon you or they're going to judge
you or they're going to cheer and yeah
they get to choose all of that not y'all
what you all get to choose is what kind
of
ecosystem kind of environment are y'all
going to create
so that this kid learns what love is
and learns that they have value and
learns how to be a good citizen a good
person
and hopefully a good
mom or husband or dad or brother or
sister
in the future right
but y'all are in it now
how does that sound just that stark like
this is happening
lindsey why is that making you cry um
hormones question mark i didn't hear you
what
hormones and
on this show there's one thing we don't
talk about and it's that i will not
respond
i'll just say high five lindsay
take a dive man take a dive yeah i i
yeah okay so
why does that make you cry um
i guess it just kind of
it comforting to know that
i'm not doing this by myself that i have
a partner in xander awesome
and but
we get to do
this raise this kid together yeah so
xander when you hear that
that the idea that you're in this too
gives her peace
how do you feel that makes me really
happy
awesome especially with everything
that's been going on
i just wanted to have peace and feel
safe okay
so here's a couple of quick points of
clarification um you're in grad school
how long is your program lindsay
uh two years and you just finished year
one
okay um are you gonna stay in that state
that you're in are you gonna move back
that depends on where i get a job after
school awesome
so xander are you still an undergrad
right what year are you
so i did two years of mechanical
engineering i had a lot of
issues with my mindset and who i was at
that time
don't care about any of that where are
you headed i don't care where you've
been where are you i'm
right now the plan for me is to get
lindsay through
the rest of her grad school make sure
our kids safe and happy and healthy
and then we'll and finish mine i love it
my mechanical engineering
those do not have to be mutually
exclusive i do think
with the amount of money that we're able
to make right now
it seems like the he's
really one of the only ways to do it
okay absolutely so
if i'm you i'll i'll let you i think
there's ways to do it but i will
that's that's your different phone call
um that the most important thing is
that you've got your priorities straight
and so i'm high-fiving you
okay if i'm you i am
the second this semester is over i am
moving to wherever she is
right i'm gonna get a the cheapest crap
comically crappy apartment i can
and i'm going to start working 17 jobs
right yeah the job interview lined up uh
this afternoon
a video interview set up for outstanding
high five okay um you're doing it right
now have you all told mom yet
yeah how'd that go both set the parents
though okay how'd that go
real real quick how'd it go great okay
it wasn't great
how about your parents xander my parents
are very supportive of us
uh they're obviously a little
disappointed that this happened before
we're done with school
but they know that they can't do
anything about it no one can other than
give us
and our kids the best environment moving
forward
awesome so and lindsay
your mom was devastated and dramatic and
oh my little girl and all that
yeah for a while it's getting better now
awesome incrementally
so that's been my experience that the
closer she comes to
getting to hold her grandbaby the more
she begins to soften
the more your boundaries are firm and
strong
and this is what we me and xander are
going to do for our kid
this is what this is going to look like
the more she will come around to it or
she'll opt out but
most of the time people opt in
and man when that when she sees that
grandkid things melt
or she turns bananas who knows
i'm gonna live in the optimism that when
she sees you guys standing up tall
you finishing up school xander you
working 17 jobs and then another one on
top of that
to create a well of financial reserve
for this family
for her grandkid that's awesome that is
fantastic
here's what you should not expect going
forward
you should not expect to be left alone
you're going to get so much stupid dumb
obnoxious ridiculous unasked for advice
over the next year year and a half two
years
okay most of the time that's people
trying to love you the best they know
how
they're just trying okay um you can say
thanks so much for sharing or
i prefer not to talk about that right
now let's talk about this
and you let people have their boundaries
both of you have to get a couple of
people that you trust
and that support you and that you
love to speak into you okay xander
you're gonna have to get some men in
your life that you trust
that will say hey idiot you got to be
doing better
harder why are you hanging out with us
you got a pregnant wife at home get your
butt home
and make sure she's doing okay right
lindsay you're going to have to have
people who will
honor and love xander for the hard
worker that he is his i mean
his impulse is great i've talked to
people like well i'm just going to
finish school and then in two years
i'll move no i mean i'm quitting it all
and we're gonna i'm gonna put what i was
gonna do on the line because now i got a
kid and i got other responsibilities are
more important
that tells me at least out of the gate
the guy's got some level of character
okay you're on the right path are you
gonna make everybody happy here no
are y'all gonna do whatever comes your
way together yes
the question you all need to answer is
are we gonna get married out of the gate
what's our relationship gonna
our romantic relationship gonna look
like it can get real easy to turn this
next couple of
six or seven or eight or nine months
into um
job tasks and you lose each other in
this and you're all going to need each
other
and so i want you guys immediately
to get a relationship counselor
immediately
to work through the relational aspects
of this because there's going to be some
job stuff you got to earn money
you got to be healthy you got to sleep
you got to get your assignments turned
in
but there's also something else going
along this way which is
lindsay you can't go through this by
yourself your bodies are going to change
your hormones
allegedly change i'm just kidding
everything's going to change for you
and you need somebody alongside you
saying i love you i love you i love you
and xander you're about to be a dad
everything you know is about to get
turned upside down slapped up flipped up
and reversed
and you need lindsey walking alongside
you saying
i'm so glad you're with me and y'all
just have to learn some new schools
new tools and some new skills
y'all are in it so thank you so much for
telling us about this i think you're on
the right track i think you're doing the
right things
i'm proud of you guys for saying okay
this happened now what's next
and xander i don't want you to ever
forget that the moment lindsay heard
xander's all in
she wept publicly
and lindsay i don't want you to forget
that xander said all right everything
stops i'm all in
i'm all in we would have done it in a
different order
if we planned it that way but we didn't
it happened and so here we go
i'm going to recommend man y'all been
together a year
you said you love him he's your guy you
said you love her she's your guy
i'd recommend y'all get married but i
want you all to meet with somebody
and go through that process make sure
you're all on the same page relationally
okay best of luck to you let us know
after the baby's born how we can
cheer you guys on and if you got a photo
or something send it to us and we'll
show
everybody the picture after baby's born
grandparents mother's in law
when you find out that you're about to
have an unplanned grandkid you got two
choices
to grieve the fact that your picture's
gonna be different and then be all in on
that kid
all in on your kid you remember how
lonely it was when you're pregnant
or all in on that grandkid or you can
grieve that your picture's going to be
different you can throw a temper tantrum
and starve that new grandkid of their
grandparents starve your child
of the season they need their parents
the most
right and you get to lecture by the way
kids get over yourselves let your
parents lecture you and give you advice
that's just what they do that's cool
but guys rally around each other we're
all in it together okay
thank you so much for the call lindsey
and xander we're high fiving you
make good choices stay in school don't
do drugs all that after school special
stuff good job
all right let me wrap up today's show um
this song is for you xander just imagine
lindsay singing it to you it's off the
1999
record fan mail
it's from tlc and the song's called no
scrubs and it goes like this
a scrub is a guy that thinks he's fly is
also known as a busta
always talking about what he wants and
just sits on his oh my to say broke ass
he sits on his broke ass so no i don't
want your number i don't want you
want to give you mine and no i don't
want to meet you nowhere
no i don't want none of your time no i
don't want no scrub
xander she just wants you she just wants
you
hiding out the passenger side of his
best friend's ride trying to hollow me
lindsay you don't want no scrubs xander
finish a semester
and get to moving this has been the dr
john dolone show
[Music]
you